let's think a little bit about what it
means to multiply fractions say i want
to multiply one-half
times
one-fourth
well one way to think about this is we
could view this as one-half of a fourth
and what do i mean there well let me
take a hole
let me take a hole here
and let me divide it into fourths
so let me divide it into fourths
so i'll divide it into four equal
sections
and so 1 4 would be one of these four
equal sections
but we want to take one half of that so
how do we take half of that well we
could divide this into two equal
sections and then just take one of them
so divide it into two equal sections
and then take one of them
so we're taking this pink area is one
half and we're gonna take or say this
pink area this whole pink area is one
fourth and now we're going to take half
of it
we're now going to take half of it so
that's this yellow square right over
here but what fraction of the whole does
this yellow represent
well it's now represents 1 out of 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 equal sections so this right
over here
represents this represents one eighth of
the whole and so we see conceptually
that one-half times one-fourth it
completely makes sense that one-half of
one-fourth should be one eighth and it
hopefully makes sense that you get this
eight by multiplying the two times the
four you started with four equal
sections but then you divided each of
those four equal sections into two equal
sections so then you have eight total
equal sections that you split your whole
into
let's do another example but now let's
multiply two fractions that don't have
ones in the numerator so let's multiply
let's multiply two-thirds
two-thirds times
times
four
fifths and i encourage you now to pause
the video and do something very similar
to what i just did try to represent
four-fifths of a whole and then try to
represent two-thirds of that four-fifths
and see what fraction of the whole you
actually have so pause now
so let's think about this let's
represent four-fifths
so if i have a hole like this
let me try to divide it into five equal
sections
five equal sections so let's say that is
one equal section
that is two equal sections that is three
four and five i can do a better job than
this this is always the hard part
trying my best to make them look at
least like equal sections two
three
four and five i think you get the point
here i'm trying to make them equal
sections
and we want four fifths so we want four
of these five equal sections so this
would be one
of the five equal sections two of them
three of them
and then four of them so that right over
there is four-fifths now we can view
this as two-thirds of the four-fifths so
how can we think about that well we
could take this section and divide it
into thirds so let's do that
divide it into thirds so we're gonna
divide into three equal sections
so that's one-third and then two-thirds
so we took each of the five equal
sections and we divided them into three
equal sections
now what's going to be two-thirds of the
four-fifths well that's going to be
that's going to be this part right over
here
so let me make this clear this
this
is one third of the four-fifths
and then if we could this would be
two-thirds of the four-fifths so this
right over here would be two-thirds of
the four-fifths or two-thirds times
four-fifths but what fraction of the
whole does that represent well how many
total
how many total equal sections do we now
have well we have one two three four
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15. so we have 15
equal sections let me do this in a new
color we have 15 equal sections and that
makes sense we started with five equal
sections but then we divided each of
those into three equal sections so now
we have five times three total equal
sections and then how many of those are
now colored in well we see it's two
times four one two three four five six
seven eight or how many how many of them
are in the two-thirds of the four-fifths
i should say and there's eight of them
eight of the 15 equal sections and so
there you have it it should hopefully
now make visual sense or it makes
conceptual sense that two-thirds times
four-fifths you can obviously compute it
by just multiplying the numerators two
times four is eight and then multiplying
the denominators three times five is
fifteen but hopefully this now makes
conceptual sense as two-thirds of
four-fifths